YUFENG GUO: One of the top
things that I get asked about
is AutoML.
In this two-part
video, let's try
using AutoML Vision to build and
deploy a machine learning model
that recognizes
different types of chairs
along with a few other items
sprinkled in for good measure.
We're doing it all--
from the raw data
collection, all the way
to serving the model, and
everything in between.
Welcome to "AI
Adventures," where
we explore the art, science,
and tools of machine learning.
My name is Yufeng Guo.
And on this episode, we'll
explore AutoML Vision,
currently in alpha,
and get our data
into the right
format as an input.
In part 2, we'll use this
data to build a model
to detect what style of
chair is in a picture.
One of the things that
makes AutoML so compelling
is having a custom model.
Existing models and services,
like the Vision API,
have no problem recognizing
that these pictures have
chairs in them.
But what if you made
your own chairs,
and that you needed
a way to catalog
the various brands of different
chairs in your inventory?
Wouldn't it be nice to be
able to use a custom Vision
API, so to speak,
which recognizes
your particular chairs?
That's what we're going to
try to do with AutoML Vision.
AutoML Vision takes as
an input lots and lots
of labeled photos.
So get your camera out and
start snapping pictures.
How many pictures you ask?
Well, ideally,
you'd have hundreds
of pictures per object.
And that would be good.
And then, once you get tired of
clicking that shutter option,
perhaps you'll try
doing what I did to get
lots and lots of pictures.
To make it easier to
capture data for AutoML,
I chose to gather
my training data
by capturing videos
of the chairs
and then using the tool ffmpeg
to extract out those frames.
I've gone out over to the
Google Sunnyvale campus.
I took some videos of a variety
of different outdoor chairs.
I also took some video of the
tables they were positioned
around, as well as a bike-- eh--
just to make things a
little more interesting.
Let's take a look at
some of that footage now.
Here, we have some chairs
of different shapes, styles,
and colors.
No video is greater than
30 seconds in length.
And we have a short clip of a
table and another of a bike.
That's the data that we
will be working with.
The end state that
we want is a CSV file
that has one row per
image and two columns--
the first for the location
of the image in Google Cloud
Storage, and the
second for the label,
like red chair or
table or blue chair.
To make it easier to
organize, I placed each video
in its own folder.
So then we can run ffmpeg
on each video file in turn
within those folders.
That way, once the
frames are extracted out,
you'll have one folder
per label filled
with images of just that label.
This is a handy way to
organize your images and data.
And it's simpler than
having one massive folder
of all the images intermingled.
Next, we can upload images
to Google Cloud Storage,
using gsutil, replicating
our folder structure
of one folder per label.
Now, it's time to get to
work creating a CSV file that
lists the path and label
for each image I wanted
to include in my data set.
Now, there's lots of
ways to accomplish this.
But I chose to spin up
a local Jupyter notebook
and create a Pandas
data-frame that
gets exported as a CSV file.
Let's walk through
that code now.
OK, so here we are in
our Jupyter notebook.
And I've imported
OS and Pandas, so we
can work with the file system.
And load up Pandas-- that way we
can use that to export our CSV.
I've listed out all
the folders that I want
to use to pull in the data.
And I've listed this
out here explicitly
because, perhaps in
a different scenario,
I might choose to use just
a subset of these folders
to create a different
training set.
So then we have a
setup here to create
a dictionary of our
folder name and then
mapping to an array of all
of our files for that folder.
And so to do that,
first, I'm going
to create an array of arrays
of just all those file names.
Each inner array is all the
file names of one folder.
And the outer array is
just for each folder.
And so here, we're listing
through all the files
in a folder.
So our data folder is here.
And we'll wrap that in an array
so that we can capture that.
And so we can see,
here, I've printed
a sample of one value, one
image, in each of the folders.
And we can see that
they're all different.
So it looks like
we're in good shape.
And so we can take those two--
our folder names
and all our file
names-- and zip them together.
Pass them to create
a dictionary.
Using that and our base
Google Cloud Storage path,
we can glue these two
together, because we
want to pre-pen the GCS, or
Google Cloud Storage path,
in the final output.
So what we want is
something like this,
where we have the Google
Cloud Storage directory path,
all the way out to the .jpeg
name, and then a comma,
and then the name of the label.
So in this case,
maybe we have a comma
and then chair_black, like so.
And so to do that, we'll loop
over the entire dictionary.
And for each file in
the array of file names
in that dictionary,
we will put together
the base Google
Cloud Storage path,
along with the folder
name and file name,
as well as that label.
So now, what we have with us
here is an array of pairs.
Each pair has that
path and the label.
So we can take this
array and just pass it
straight into a data frame.
Pandas accepts that
format to create new data
frames from scratch.
And our data frame looks
exactly as we'd expect.
We got all our paths
and all our labels.
Now, we're ready
to export to CSV.
In this particular case,
we want to export such
that we use index equals
false and header equals false.
This is important and
can really trip you up
if you forget to do this.
Because if you leave
the defaults, which
are index-- true,
and header-- true,
the outputted CSV file will
have a header row of 0 and 1.
And moreover, it will
have an index column
that comes before everything
else, which is just going
to be your 0, 1, 2, 3, 4, 5.
So we don't want any of that.
We just want the
path to the file
and the label, nothing else.
So we use index-- false,
and header-- false.
So if you organize your folder
structure the same way that I
have mine, you can
take this notebook
and, with a couple
of minimal changes,
adapt it for your
use case as well.
So I'll definitely publish
this notebook and link
to that down below in
the video description.
All right, so now
we have a CSV file
describing the location and
label for all the images
in our data set.
We're ready to train our model.
Join me in part 2
of this episode.
And we'll see just how well
this model can perform.
Thanks for watching this episode
of "Cloud AI Adventures."
And if you enjoyed it, hit
that Like button down below.
And be sure to subscribe to get
all the latest updates right
when they come out.
And while you head over
to part two of this video,
I'm going to eat this--
mm-- apple.
[MUSIC PLAYING]